to see his emotions do that because he's  about to lose this game no  no magnets have to be careful I  mentioned two King moves I'm slightly  worried that one of them will walk into  some tracks  okay definitely not to the I was about  to say definitely not to the E file but  we can come to the B3 Square  wow this is really interesting losing  blunder yes completely winning to  completely losing in one move well  and look at Duda suddenly he's uh yeah  energized again what is happening good  for Judah that he did save some time on  his clock Magnus laughing at his blunder  now  yeah if you put the King on the other  Square it was winning but now we see  this is the Block it's the Discover  check white hits the black king this was  why it was a poor choice of square  and uh and why is it a loss because the  queen cannot be taken that's true I  guess the black king is just so open  Queen and Rook end games for example